to women's safety volunteers who were
arrested at morning to you Mick um stop
there shall we
um talk to us about those volunteers
because they worked for for the night
team at Westminster city council am I
right yeah yeah it's called it's called
night stars and it is a program run by
uh in conjunction with the Metropolitan
Police and uh Westminster city council
uh the Westminster Council have
um put out a statement expressing their
discomfort with the fact that the Met
has a you know lifted volunteers who
look after women's safety but not just
women's safety safety of people who are
out at night
um now the issue here really is that
they were arrested by the territorial
support group who are you know the kind
of the Heavies and that whose job is to
handle protests
they're on
their oh sorry I'm hearing other
people's audio in my head in my ears
there which isn't helpful
um the Metropolitan Police
um would normally work with these people
so they wouldn't have arrested them
because they would know and recognize
them they're there most Friday and
Saturday night so that was a problem and
they were arrested for 14 hours uh held
a release without charge but released
without an apology and they were um
arrested because there was a search area
in place they were searched and they had
um they they had rape alarms on them now
uh the mail on Sunday had reported a
couple of weeks previously that there
was a plot to use rape alarms to throw
them at horses now the source for the
mail and Sunday story I'm told was the
Metropolitan Police and the Metropolitan
police's head of media is a former male
journalist now of course the
Metropolitan Police would deny that
there's any problem there or that they
uh were involved in um sort of putting
that information out and then acting on
that information and I'm sure that
you'll have a statement from them but um
yeah that's the situation
well the anti-monarchy group Republic
Mick they're saying look hang on this is
heavy-handed and this is a direct attack
on democracy and lots of conversations
are starting to happen uh around the
Metropolitan Police and they're handling
generally of uh Saturday's coronation
procession that's true that's true
there's something I mean I don't
I I your question is wealth well well
put but one thing I would like to say is
that I I know Graham Smith from Republic
I I spent a lot of time with people from
Republic who were waiting to try and get
their uh their colleagues out of uh out
of custody over the weekend they are not
an anti-monarchy group they are a
pro-republic group and the language
matters because
um I'm a republican I believe that we
can be like the Irish state where I live
for eight years I'm caught or Irish
um the the you know our island has a
republic and it has a non-executive
president it's not that I hate Prince
Charles it's that I do not a King
Charles sorry it's that I don't believe
the monarchy is the best way to run the
art system and so the problem with um
the problem with uh uh working along
saying anti-monarchy group is it
presumes that they're negative rather
than positive and the positive is we
would like there to be a republic
because we think it would be better for
everyone rather than we we are you know
sour face lemon sucking
um you know
dislikers of of fun and flags you know
that's a problem
oh lemon's great and a gin and tonic
make I can tell you yeah and the other
thing I'd like to say is I am not a
member of Republic I am an independent
journalist okay I'm not a member of any
of the activist groups though I I
support their efforts and and I believe
that they were unlawfully arrested and I
think that's important to know okay Mick
really briefly um the Metropolitan
Police have said look their tolerance
for protesting in particular for this
event was very low
um they're citing that people had
traveled from near and far to enjoy the
celebrations what do you say to that the
Met police uh the Met police would not
engage with me as a journalist when I
tried to get comment from them and then
they quote tweeted me on Twitter to uh
pretend that my reporting my reporting
that they'd uh arrested people who were
not even protesters they suggested that
that was untrue the Met are lying I'm
afraid to say they would say they're not
lying I think that the commissioner has
uh questions to answer in Parliament
recently he quite rightly directed Lee
Anderson the Tory party chair who said
Republicans like me should be expelled
from the country he corrected him on the
law the the police did not apply the law
evenly accurately or correctly and the
new laws are framed in such a way that
practically anything can be seen as
protest and for us as journalists it's a
problem because I was a nuisance to the
Metropolitan Police this weekend and if
the police deemed me a sufficient
nuisance they could arrest me and they
did arrest journalists over the weekend
free speech is under threat it's not
under threat from trans people or
leftists it's under threat from the
government and the Metropolitan Police
okay good to get your thoughts so that's
mcwright journalists there talking about
police and the the handling of the
coronation